>>> THE PEOPLE WHO CONTESTED AND
CONTINUE TO CONTEST THE 2020
ELECTION NOW USING IT AS A
CAMPAIGN PLATFORM.
REMEMBER, THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT
2020.
THIS IS ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THE
COUNTRY.
JOHN AVLON WITH A REALITY CHECK.
>> THE TRUMP ENDORSED KAENLT FOR
ARIZONA GOVERNOR, FORMER LOCAL
FOX ANCHOR, CARRIE LAKE SAID SHE
WOULD NOT HAVE CERTIFIED THE
2020 ELECTION CITING INFORMATION
ABOUT SERIOUS IRREGULARITIES,
DESPITE THE FACT THE
HYPERPARTISAN CONCLUDED BIDEN
WON THE STATE BY A LARGER MARGIN
THAN INITIALLY REPORTED.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT THE FACTS.
IT'S ABOUT THE CULT OF THE BIG
LIE AND PEOPLE WHO BACK THIS
B.S. ARE NOT PATRIOTS.
THEY'RE EITHER COWARDS ARE
FOOLS, COWARDS OF POLITICIANS
WHO PRIVATELY KNOW BETTER AND
FOOLS IF THEY CONTINUE TO BE
DUPED BY AN ANTI CONSTITUTIONAL
CONMAN.
EITHER WAY, THEY'RE COMPLICIT IN
AN ONGOING ATTEMPT TO UNDERMINE
OUR DEMOCRACY.
REVIEW THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION IN A STATE HE WON BY
FIVE POINTS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THIS IS ABOUT
VALIDATING VOTER SUPPRESSION AND
ELECTION SUBVERSION, BECAUSE
ALREADY, GOP LEGISLATORS IN AT
LEAST 18 STATES HAVE ENACTED 30
NEW LAWS THAT DO THINGS LIKE
EMPOWER STATE OFFICIALS TO TAKE
CONTROL OF COUNTY ELECTION
BOARDS, STRIP SECRETARIES OF
STATE OF THEIR EXECUTIVE
AUTHORITY OR MAKE LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIALS CRIMINALLY OR
FINANCIALLY LIABLE EVEN FOR
TECHNICAL ERRORS AND GET THIS,
10 OF THE 15 REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR SECRETARY
OF STATE IN FIVE BATTLEGROUNDS
STILL QUESTION WHETHER TRUMP
REALLY LOST THE ELECTION,
ACCORDING TO REUTERS.
THIS F THEY WIN THAT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF PUTTING THE MEMBER
OF THE FLAT EARTH SOCIETY IN
CHARGE OF NASA.
TRUMP'S LIES HAVE TAKEN OVER THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, DISFIGURING
OUR DEMOCRACY AND A TEST TO
DOWNPLAY THE DANGER ARE NO
LIKELY TO AGE BETTER THAN
MULVANEY'S OP-ED PROMISING IF HE
LOSES, TRUMP WILL CONCEDE
GRACEFULLY, AS THE TRUMP VIRUS
CONTINUES TO SPREAD, WE NEED TO
INOCULATE OUR DEMOCRACY FROM ITS
INTENDED EFFECT WHICH IS THE
OVERTURNING OF AN ELECTION.
WHILE SENATOR JOE MANCHIN
CONSIDERING HIS QUIXOTIC EFFORT
TO CONVINCE TEN REPUBLICANS TO
VOTE FOR HIS REFORM BILL THERE'S
A MORE TARGETED EFFORT WHICH
COULD GAIN REPUBLICAN SUPPORT AN
URGENTLY NEEDED CLARIFICATION OF
AN 1887 LAW KNOWN AS THE
ELECTORAL COUNT ACT THE SAME
MURKY AND MESSY LAW JOHN EASTMAN
ATTEMPTED TO EXPLOIT IN HIS
SIX-POINT MEMO FOR HOW TO
CONDUCT A COUP.
AMONG THE LAW'S MANY
DEFICIENCIES IT ALLOWS STATE
LEGISLATORS TO APPOINT A SLATE
OF ELECTORS REGARDLESS OF HOW
CITIZENS VOTED IF THE STATE
FAILED TO MAKE A CHOICE ON
ELECTION DAY, A CIRCUMSTANCE THE
LAW DOES NOT CURRENTLY DEFINE.
IN ADDITION, IT ALLOWS AN
OBJECTION TO THE COUNTING OF
ELECTORAL VOTES TO OCCUR IF ONE
SENATOR AND MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
SIGN ON.
THE LAW DOES NOT GIVE THE VICE
PRESIDENT DISCRETION TO IGNORE
STATE ELECTORS AS TRUMP
REPORTEDLY WANTED MIKE PENCE TO
DO SAYING WOULDN'T IT BE ALMOST
COOL TO HAVE THAT POWER?
HE SAID THAT.
TO REMOVE ANY TEMPTATIONS THE
VICE PRESIDENT IS A MERE
FUNCTION WEAR WHEN IT COMES TO
COUNTING ELECTION RESULTS.
THIS REFORM IS NEEDED TO AVOID
ANOTHER CONTESTED ELECTION AND A
NEW CONSTITUTION CRISIS AND
CROSS-AISLE REPEAL BACKED BY AEI
AND THE KATO INSTITUTE.
FANATICS DON'T CARE ABOUT FACTS
AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN OUR LAWS NOW.
SO ATTEMPTS TO OVERTURN THE NEXT
ELECTION BY TRUMP APARATCHIKS DO
NOT SUCCEED.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I BRING IN CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR FROM UTAH MIA LOVE.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
AS JOHN POINTS OUT THE ISSUE NOW
IS THAT THERE ARE REPUBLICANS
RUNNING FOR OFFICE FOR WHOM THE
BIG LIE IS A CENTRAL PLATFORM
AND IN 2024 THEY'D BE IN A
POSITION TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
>> CARRIE LAKE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
SHE'S GOING TOARIZONA, HOW SHE'
MAKE THINGS BETTER, INSTEAD THE
MAIN CAMPAIGN PLATFORM SHE WOULD
HAVE DONE THINGS DIFFERENTLY
THAN GOVERNOR DUCEY, SHE
WOULDN'T HAVE CERTIFIED THE
ELECTIONS SO IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING BECAUSE SHE IS NOT
GIVING ANYBODY IN ARIZONA ANY
HOPES AS TO WHAT SHE WILL BE
DOING.
IT'S COMPLETELY FOCUSED ON
WHETHER IT'S HER IDEA OR NOT,
WHETHER IT'S WHAT SHE WANTS TO
DO OR NOT, SHE MADE THE
STATEMENT THAT SHE WOULD NOT
HAVE CERTIFIED THE VOTES, SO
THAT'S WHAT THE CAMPAIGN HAS
BECOME ABOUT, INSTEAD OF HEY,
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
IN THE FUTURE AND HOW WE'RE
GOING TO HELP ARIZONA REALLY
HAVE A LEG UP.
>> WHAT'S TO KEEP, IF SOME OF
THESE CANDIDATES GET ELECTED,
WHAT'S TO KEEP THEM FROM
OVERTURNING AN ELECTION GOING
FORWARD?
>> WELL, UNFORTUNATELY, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S TO KEEP THEM FROM
DOING THAT AND I THINK THAT IT'S
GOING TO, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE
HER PRIORITIES ARE, SAME THING
WITH GREG ABBOTT.
INSTEAD OF PLEDGING HIS
ALLEGIANCE TO DONALD TRUMP, HE
REALLY NEEDS TO PLEDGE HIS
ALLEGIANCE TO THE UNITED STATES
AND TO THE STATE OF TEXAS, AND
IT SEEMS AS IF THEY'RE REMOVING
THEMSELVES FROM THE VERY PEOPLE
THAT HAVE VOTED THEM IN, AND ARE
FOCUSING ON WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO RUN FOR
OFFICE AGAIN, AND UNFORTUNATELY
I THINK THAT SOME OF THESE
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE HEDGING
THEIR BETS AND I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE DETRIMENTAL NOT JUST
FOR THEM BUT FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY REPRESENT.
>> WELL, WHAT IS THE INCENTIVE
STRUCTURE RIGHT NOW INSIDE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
ISN'T THE INCENTIVE STRUCTURE
SET UP FOR THEM TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE DOING?
>> WELL, THE INCENTIVE I THINK
WHAT THEY'RE AFRAID OF IS, ONE,
NOT BEING ABLE TO FUNDRAISE.
THEY'RE USING THAT TRUMP TRAIN
IN ORDER TO GAIN MONEY AND IT'S
THE OUTSIDE OF THAT, THE
ABSOLUTE OPPOSITE OF THAT WHICH
IS FEAR, AND THAT FEAR IS I'M
NOT GOING TO GET THE SUPPORT OR
THE MONEY THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
GET, AND RIGHT NOW, WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING IN TERMS OF REPUBLICANS,
THERE IS THIS TURMOIL, INSTEAD
OF TALKING ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON, WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE STATE, THEY'RE
TRYING TO, IT'S
SELF-PRESERVATION.
IT'S TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GET THE VOTES THAT THEY
WANT AND THE FUNDING THAT THEY
WANT, AND I THINK THAT THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE THAT REALLY NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS AND SAY I DON'T
NEED TRUMP IN ORDER TO DO THIS.
THERE ARE SO MANY -- HE IS THE
PAST.
IN ORDER FOR THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY TO ACTUALLY MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT THE PRESIDENT, THEY NEED
TO IGNORE THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
SAID OVER THE WEEKEND AT YAHOO!
FINANCE.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS, WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
RON DeSANTIS RAN IN A
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY.
HE SAID "IF I FACED HIM, I'D
BEAT HIM LIKE I'D BEAT ANYONE
ELSE.
I DON'T THINK I WILL FACE HIM.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE WOULD DROP
OUT.
I THINK HE WOULD DROP OUT."
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> I THINK RON DeSANTIS -- I
WORKED WITH RON DeSANTIS BEFORE
AND RON DeSANTIS SHOULD CONTINUE
TO RUN FOR GOVERNOR AND FOR THE
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA AND NOT TO
WORRY ABOUT DONALD TRUMP AND I
THINK RON DeSANTIS WOULD GIVE
HIM A RUN FOR HIS MONEY.
AGAIN, THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
BE, THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S GOING
TO BE ON YOUR SIDE AS LONG AS
YOU PLEDGE YOUR ALLEGIANCE TO
HIM.
THAT IS IT, AND IF YOU SHOW
SIGNS THAW ARE MOVING AWAY AND
THAT YOU HAVE YOUR OWN
ASPIRATIONS, WATCH OUT, BECAUSE